- Welcome back y'all.
Our next guest is a mesmerizing
folk singer songwriter
who already has one Grammy under her belt
and this year she's
nominated for three more
for her latest album, "Age of Apathy."
Great title. Now
performing her moving song,
"Prodigal Daughter." Give
it up for Aoife O'Donovan
along with Allison Russell.
(audience cheering and applauding)
(soft guitar music)
♪ Oh now Rosie ♪
♪ You come home in the morning ♪
♪ Got a child on your knee
and your mother she looks on ♪
♪ Says I don't know that baby ♪
♪ Don't know you why'd you fail me ♪
♪ You left home seven years
ago and I wore black for days ♪
♪ Prodigal daughter returns
like a lamb to the slaughter ♪
♪ I know forgiveness won't
come easy, not for you ♪
♪ Look at the child upon my knee ♪
♪ She has eyes of blue ♪
♪ She resembles me resembling you ♪
♪ Mama, listen ♪
♪ Come into the kitchen ♪
♪ Pour me some tea, let me sit
at your feet and let me cry ♪
♪ I need a little money ♪
♪ I need love, and I need Sunday ♪
♪ Suppers here at home,
don't want to be alone ♪
♪ Let me stay ♪
♪ I wanna stay ♪
♪ Prodigal daughter returns
like a lamb to the slaughter ♪
♪ She yearns for the things
that you taught her ♪
♪ I know forgiveness won't
come easy, not for me ♪
♪ But I'll try to shut the past
behind us, throw out the key ♪
♪ Give me one more
chance to make you see ♪
(soft guitar music continues)
♪ Prodigal daughter returns
like a lamb to the slaughter ♪
♪ Looking for something in the water ♪
♪ To wash away the pain ♪
♪ Wash away the pain ♪
♪ She's drowning in the pain ♪
♪ Drowning in the pain ♪
♪ To wash away the pain ♪
♪ Wash away the pain ♪
♪ She's drowning in the pain ♪
♪ Drowning in the pain ♪
♪ To wash away the pain ♪
♪ Wash away the pain ♪
♪ She's drowning in the pain ♪
♪ Drowning in the pain ♪
♪ To wash away the pain ♪
♪ Wash away the pain ♪
♪ Wash away ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- One more time for Aoife
O'Donovan everybody,
her album "Age of Apathy" is out now.
Get it wherever you get your music